food is a human right say these people
in the center of buenos aires
they gathered in argentina's capital to
demand more government help
cevatian suicidal says poverty rates are
on the rise
and millions of people are struggling to
survive
we understand the way out is with work
and that we're in a complex situation
but there are resources
the government will have to choose
whether to continue paying for foreign
debt
or take care of those people that can
barely make ends meet the pandemic poses
a major challenge for argentina
the government is already assisting over
10 million people with food and cash
handouts
but the economy has deteriorated rapidly
the country is struggling to pay its
foreign debts and still
every day around 20 000 new infections
are confirmed
there is an evening curfew here in the
capital and access to public transport
is limited
but authorities are reluctant to declare
another full lockdown like they did last
year
fearing the consequences that might come
from closing the economy completely
there is no social margin to shut down
everything there are lots of people that
don't eat meat if they don't work the
government has fewer tools than they did
last year
and that's why it's crucial they
accelerate the vaccination campaign
they cannot focus only on restrictions
because there is no support and there is
need on the street
even though argentina has one of the
strongest public health care
systems in latin america institutions
and workers here are under stress
the rising infections in these past
weeks have most hospitals in buenos
aires
at full capacity in some locations
they're already transferring patients to
other
areas in order to cope with a demand in
this hospital people have been waiting
for hours
to go inside an emergency room antonio
lauriano
is a construction worker and says he
rushed to the hospital because he was
feeling ill
my throat hurts my back hurts i have
difficulty breathing
i've been waiting for a while to see a
doctor
but experts say this is the beginning of
a second wave
with a long winter ahead and scars
resources
authorities are evaluating when is the
best time
to shut down buenos aires